I'm meteorologist Anthony Farnell with a
look at what to expect across Canada for
this upcoming winter season you've
likely heard of terms like lanin and El
Nino well this winter El Nino will play
a significant role in the weather
pattern across Canada and really across
the Northern Hemisphere after three
straight years of cooler than normal
Waters in the equator region of the
Pacific we've seen a weakening of the
trade winds what does that mean well
with weaker Trade Winds coming off South
America you don't get upwelling you
don't get that cold water so warmer
water temperatures affect the jet stream
and across much of Canada that means a
weaker polar jet so milder air comes in
from the Pacific you get less Arctic
outbreaks and generally a warmer weather
pattern also means less snowfall where
are the storms well they are more likely
with this subtropical Jet subpolar and
that moves through California into Texas
and then off the east coast with above
normal rainfall and cooler temperatures
although Atlantic Canada will likely see
not just cooler air but also numerous
storms this season now not every El Nino
is alike in fact they're very different
and this year could be a bit different
because of climate change the Atlantic
above average water temperatures the
Indian Ocean above seasonal the Western
Pacific as well and it's not just water
temperatures that are warm but the air
is about a degree and a half globally
higher than typical over the
pre-industrial levels so all of this
impacts our seasonal forecast but we are
going to be into a mild start the month
of December forecasted mild just about
from Coast to Coast to Coast January
starting actually around Christmas in
the holidays it turns colder in the
Great Lakes through the eastern part of
Canada and the maritimes while still
above seasonal temperatures out west
February also looking warm here while it
stays cool and unsettled in Quebec and
through Labrador in New Finland so as a
whole it's mild this winter out west now
what does that mean well even a
temperature over the entire 3-month
period of two degrees above seasonal in
Winnipeg and Saskatoon that's still
pretty cold there are going to be bouts
of winter for sure but as a whole on
average it will be milder out west and
likely cooler as we get further away
from the El Nino effects as far as
rainfall and snowfall and ice storm
potential that's there the last major
ice storm in 1998 Ice Storm of the
Century it was called well that was in
an Al Nino year for southwestern Quebec
so we're going to keep an eye on that
setup it looks Stormy in the maritimes
below seasonal snowfall out west and
Below seasonal around the Great Lakes as
well and that is a look at your winter
forecast across
Canada